is it fascinating to you
that viruses are doing this i mean it
feels like they're this intelligent
organism
i mean is it like does it give you pause
how
incredible it is that they are um the
the evolutionary dynamics that you're
describing is actually happening
and they're freaking out figuring out
how to jump from bass to humans
all in this distributed fashion and then
most of us don't even say they're alive
or intelligent whatever
so intelligence is in the eye of the
beholder
you know stupid is a stupid does as far
as gum would say
yes and intelligence is as intelligent
does so basically if the virus is
finding solutions that we think of in
intelligent yeah it's probably
intelligent
but that's again in the eye of the
beholder do you think viruses are
intelligent
of course not really no
because it's so incredible so remember
remember when i was talking about the
two components of evolution
one is the stupid mutation yeah which is
completely blind and the other one is
the
super smart selection which is ruthless
so it's not viruses who are smart it's
this component of evolution that's smart
so it's evolution that that sort of
appears smart
and how is that happening by huge
parallel search across thousands of
you know parallel infections throughout
the world right now
yes but so to perfect on that so yes
so then the the intelligence is in the
mechanism
but then uh by that argument uh viruses
would be more intelligent because
there's just more of them
so the search they're basically the the
brute force
search that's happening with viruses
because there's so many more of them
than humans
then they're taken as a whole are more
intelligent
i mean so you don't think it's possible
that
i i mean who runs would we even be here
with if viruses weren't
i mean who runs this thing so
the virus so let me answer yeah let me
answer your your question
um so um
we would not be here if it wasn't for
viruses yes and part of the reason
is that if you look at mammalian
evolution early on in this mammalian
radiation
that basically happened after the death
of the dinosaurs is that some of the
viruses
that we had in our genome spread
throughout our genome
and created binding sites for
new classes of regulatory proteins and
these
binding sites that landed all over our
genome are now control
elements that basically control our
genes and sort of
help the complexity of the circuitry of
mammalian genomes
so you know everything's co-evolution
and
we're working together but and yet you
said
them no i never said they're dumb they
just don't care
they don't care another thing oh is the
virus trying to kill us
no it's not the virus is not trying to
kill you it's true it's not it's
actually
actively trying to not kill you so when
you get infected if you die
palmer i killed him is what the reaction
of the virus will be why because that
virus won't spread
many people have a misconception of oh
viruses are smart or
viruses are mean they don't care
it's it like you have to clean yourself
of any kind of anthropomorphism
out there i don't know oh yes
there's uh there's a sense when taken as
a whole that there's um
it's in the eye of the beholder stupid
is a stupid does intelligent is a stupid
intelligence does
so if you want to call them intelligent
that's fine then that's because and the
end result
is that they're finding amazing
solutions right i mean i i mean but
they're
all they're so dumb about it they're
just doing dumb they don't care they're
not dumb and they're not interested
they don't care they care the care word
is really interesting
i mean there could be an argument that
they're conscious they're just dividing
they're not
they're just dividing they're just a
little entity
which happens to be dividing and
spreading it does
doesn't want to kill us in fact it
prefers not to kill us
it just wants to spread and when i say
once again i'm anthropomorphizing
but it's just that if you have two
versions of a virus one acquires a
mutation that spreads more
that's going to spread more one requires
a mutation that's pressed less that's
going to be lost
yes one occurs in mutation that enters
faster that's going to be kept
one acquires a mutation that kills you
right away it's gonna be lost
so over evolutionary time the viruses
that spread super well but don't kill
the host
are the ones that are gonna survive yeah
but so
you see you brilliantly describe the
basic mechanisms of how it all happens
but when you zoom out and you see the
uh you know the entirety of viruses
maybe across
different strains of viruses it seems
like a living organism
i am in awe of biology i find biology
amazingly beautiful i find the design
of the current coronavirus however
lethal it is amazingly beautiful
the way that it is encoded the way that
it tricks
your cells into making 30 proteins from
a single rna
human cells don't do that human cells
make
one protein from each rna molecule they
don't make two
they make one we are hardwired to make
only one protein
from every rna molecule and yet this
virus goes in
throws in a single messenger rna
just like any messenger rna we have tens
of thousands of messengers rnas in our
cells in any one time
in every one of our cells it throws in
one rna
and that rna is so i'm going to use your
word here not my word
intelligent yeah that it hijacks the
entire machinery
of your human cell yeah it basically
has at the beginning a giant open
reading frame that's a giant protein
that gets translated
two-thirds of that rna make a single
giant protein
that single protein is basically what a
human cell would make it's like oh
here's a start codon i'm going to start
translating here human cells are kind of
dumb i'm sorry again
this is not the word that we normally
use but the human cell basically is oh
this is an rna it must be mine let me
translate
and it starts translating it and then
you're in trouble why
because that one protein as it's growing
gets cleaved into about 20 different
peptides the first peptide and the
second peptide
start interacting and the third one and
the fourth one and they
shut off the ribosome of the whole cell
to not translate human
rnas anymore so the virus basically
hijacks
your cells and it cuts it cleaves every
one of your human rnas
to basically say to the ribosome don't
translate this one junk don't look at
this one junk
and it only spares its own rnas
because they have a particular mark that
it spares then all of the ribosomes that
normally make protein
in your human cells are now only able to
translate
viral rnas and make more and more and
more and more of them
that's the first 20 proteins in fact
halfway down about
protein 11 between you know 11 and 12
you basically have a translational
slippage where the ribosome skips
reading frame
and it translates from one reading frame
to another reading frame that means that
about half of them are going to be
translated from 1 to
11 and the other half are going to be
translated from 12 to 16.
wow it's gorgeous and then
then you're done then that mrna will
never translate the elastin proteins but
spike is the one right after that one so
how does spike even get translated
this positive strand rna virus has a
reverse transcriptase
which is an rna-based reverse
transcriptase so from the rna on the
positive strand it makes an rna on the
negative strand
and in between every single one of these
genes these open reading frames
there's a little signal aac gca or
something like that
that basically loops over to the
beginning
of the rna and basically instead of sort
of having a single
full negative strand or an a it
basically has a partial negative strand
rna
that ends right before the beginning of
that gene and another one that ends
right before the beginning of that gene
these negative strand rnas now make
positive strand rnas
that then look to the human whole cell
just like any other
human mrna it's like oh great i'm going
to translate that one because it doesn't
have the cleaving that the virus has now
put on all your human genes
and then you've lost a battle that cell
is now only making
proteins for the virus that will then
create the spike protein the envelope
protein the membrane protein the
nucleocapsid protein that will package
up the rna
and then sort of create new viral
envelopes
and these will then be secreted out of
that cell
in new little packages that will then
infect the rest of the cells repeat the
whole process
beautiful right it's mine not to
anthropomorphize it
you